[Music]
buzz lightyear mission log stardate 3901
after a full year of being marooned our
first hyper speed test flight is a go
who are you talking uh no one you were
narrating again i was not just doing the
mission log you do know no one ever
listens to that i know that narrating
helps me focus
ready captain let you ready as i'll ever
be commander hawthorne this is exciting
a new adventure i'm gonna grant you four
minutes to be off planet but then you
come right back to us
to infinity and beyond
and you are clear for hyperlaunch
buzz that was utterly terrifying and i
regret having joined you
buzz lightyear to star command come in
star command
why don't they answer
hey
the robots the what
what is happening right now
alicia oh no that's my grandmother but
sucks how long were we gone yum yum yum
yum yum
years seven months and five days
what
i hope you're ready for action because
all we needed was a pilot for what to
destroy the alien ship
i have a plan and i have a team darby
can take any three things and make them
explode
i do this and they shave a little time
off my sentence okay and what about you
well i thought this was going to be like
a fun boot camp workout thing
but it is not
did i get it pretty close i need that
you know what i'm saying the harpoons
[Music]
right here
[Music]
the probability of survival with an
inexperienced crew is 38.2 hmm seems a
bit low mission failure imminent in
three grandma always said she believed
in you too
there was a big swelling too i think i
need a better don't at least record your
last words do not vomit inside the
vehicle
if you are satisfied with this recording
speak or select one
[Music]
to infinity are you trying to get me to
pull your finger don't fall for it no
not like that
sorry it's the thing your grandma and i
used to do yeah
a year of work for a four-minute flight
isn't that something we're all ready if
you are sir well let's go find out if
this
thank you
[Music]
buzz lightyear mission long
after a full year of being marooned on
this planet
our first test flight is a go
[Music]
but get everyone home good luck
captaining
roger that
[Applause]
[Music]
just a massive robot
[Music]
that was utterly terrifying and i regret
having joined you
right here
i can provide sleep sounds if you like i
have several options summer night ocean
paradise whale calls no no white noise
is fine very well good night socks good
night buzz
flight recorders are on
[Applause]
we have not
[Applause]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Music]
to infinity
and
[Music]
bye